Joe Biden won the most delegates on
Super Tuesday okay and that makes him
the frontrunner for the Democratic
nomination now this is crazy at 77 years
old 77 Biden is actually the youngest
man still in the Democratic primary he's
the youngest yeah and guess what he's
kind of gloating about it in this new ad
take a look
critics claim Joe Biden is too old to be
running for president but what they
don't realize is that he's actually the
youngest male Democratic nominee yeah
that's right he's young Joe when Bernie
was a freshman in college Joe was a mere
senior in high school what the whole
year younger yeah Jill might be 77 but
his teeth are only three years old
lightly spiced food Joe Young Valley can
handle it
agile Joe's shower only has two grab
bars and if Joe is so old explain these
sick moves my wife Joe Biden came here
to chew calcium supplements and kick ass
and he's all out of calcium supplements
Joe Biden 2020 yolo whippersnappers
[Applause]